A couple of christmases ago,
I got this,
this gift from one of our distributors
who sold me a.
It still sells us these incredible oils
from France,
from Burgundy,
and the maker is incredibly expensive.
It's this guy's so artism like he does
it in his garage behind his house.
He knows guys like another Wackadoo and
so he,
the Frenchman,
the artisanal producers,
Jeanmarc Montonya,
he gave the distributor Olivia a
president for us because we were the
biggest customer and his first,
I think one of his first and he gave us
a gift for Christmas.
Olivia handed to me and I open the box
and it's,
it's this box of,
of dust.
It smells a little bit like nuts.
It's just dust.
I was like,
you,
what the hell is it?
So Olivia says,
I'll live a,
you know,
John Mark wanted to give you a after he
a president that,
that have have nut dust.
It's basically after he presses the nuts
for his oil,
he has all this residue,
right?
So he said,
Olivia said,
you know,
last year I went over to to burgundy and
I had lunch with Sean Mark.
And as I opened the door to go into his
kitchen,
he was there on the stove,
saw tank potatoes and um,
and we sat down to,
to a salad and,
and a little like fried potatoes,
potatoes.
But Olivia said all he could taste from
the salads,
potatoes,
all I could taste,
we're Ahmed's.
He didn't see any artist.
He just smelled this overwhelming thing
was he thought like there was some kind
of almond souffle coming for dessert or
something.
And there's no honest to fly.
So he asked,
he asked mark,
he said,
mark,
you know,
it's delicious.
Meal tasting is Ahmed.
And John Mark said,
okay.
So after I pressed the,
the,
the almonds,
I have this residue,
this,
this dust is not that.
Instead of throwing it out,
I throw it onto my potato fields
and a lot of it on my potato fields.
And through this incredible process of
Osmosis,
you know,
he gets almond potatoes,
right?
So I thought,
so he's telling me this and I'm looking
at my box.
I was just like,
this is the secret to,
you know,
my millions,
right?
So I take the stuff and I called a nut
company out in California and organic
and that company asked them for like 500
pounds of,
of,
of I thought pine nuts because I thought
I could one up.
I'm like,
I started to get competitive with this
guy.
I don't even know who gave me a gift
pine that we did.
We did.
Um,
and again we did walnut.
We got all these nuts and,
and jack spread them on carrots.
I didn't want to do it with potatoes
because I thought it'd be too much
capacity.
Carrots and we have a lot of carrots
during the winter.
So we spread,
spread,
spread.
Meanwhile,
I decided,
you know,
with my brother,
we're going to make some.
I do like this special night.
We know when the harvest is coming seven
weeks after the plants and to say,
okay,
let gonna do a harvest night and we're
going to do an,
you know,
an almond carrot night because we
figured that would be the one that
worked the pestle.
Almond carrot night.
We invite the whole dining rooms packed
with people who are excited about when
we sent out this email,
we talk to people for months and months.
We get the waiter's all jazzed up on
this thing.
I mean,
everybody was,
did the coat check,
the valets.
Everybody was the cooks era was talking
about it.
So the day of the dinner comes right and
uh,
and the harvest for someone who came in
really late that afternoon and I hadn't
actually really tasted the carrot,
you know,
so it's like 4:30 and I'm bored sitting
there cleaning carrots and like I
started to taste them and right as I'm
tasting them again and you know,
too,
too much to believe,
like the tickets are coming in,
you know,
it's like five,
um,
and carrot salad,
six Almond Garrett's salads,
you know,
double order obamacare.
It's out.
And I take a bite of the carrots,
no almond flavor,
nothing.
Zero,
Zilch.
It doesn't even taste like there's a
potential for almond in the future.
There's nothing.
It's a delicious carrot.
No.
Ahmed total failure.
So I sliced the carrots are like all of
a sudden tickets are coming in and
coming in like a 30 tickets on the board
and like 500 almond south.
And so I started slicing the carrots
really quickly,
salt,
pepper,
lemon vinegarette and I reached for John
Marks,
almond oil,
of which I have a few extra bottles and
I start dousing it with almond oil and I
mix it and then I give it to the waiters
just to taste before they go out the
dining room.
Genius man,
it tastes like,
um,
it's,
it's unbelievable.
It's fucking damn is a genius,
you know.
So that night we sell 120 carat salads
and it is the greatest success in the,
his is the best night we've ever had at
Blue Hill.
Every episode I ever had any restaurant
people wrote emails.
It's still talk about it.
It was still talking about it.
People say it's the most exciting and
most delicious,
you know,
experience I've ever had in a
restaurant.
There was a buzz in the diag,
never had.
And what I realized at the end of the
night in the mayhem of plating all these
salads,
I mean it was crazy night,
I forgot to put the almond oil in the,
in the carrots I did on some,
but I didn't on a lot and it did not
matter.
It absolutely did not matter.
People taste it.
Almonds,
because you told them the story and they
tasted the most delicious character
their life because they had this funny
story that they felt invested in and
they felt a part of and they wanted to
be connected to.
I think we're hardwired for this mess.
My ultimate theory is like,
you know,
as hunter gatherers,
we were spending our time figuring out
is that thing poisonous,
that thing,
delicious.
Well that thing feed our children,
you know,
it is that thing,
nutritious,
that kind of thing.
And I don't think that's been bred out
of us,
you know?
So when someone gives you a story of
this kind of thing,
like it,
it informs us and relaxes us,
relate to taste,
things that we otherwise wouldn't taste.
So that's my,
you know,
that we have so many stories like that
that just like it teaches me again and
again,
you have a story,
you have delicious food,
you know,
as long as you really don't screw it up,
you have malicious.
So there you go.